we have to be thoughtful about how we
Embrace and integrate new technology
into our lives and I think particularly
when it comes to our kids you can judge
a society by how well it cares for and
supports and protects its children I
think under many ways we've done a great
job in society on many other fronts I
think here we drop the ball and I think
we've got to catch up and do better it's
not okay to just say well the horse is
already out of the barn so whatever is
going to happen is going to happen we
can't control it if we went back to a
time when you and I were younger when
motor vehicle accidents were really high
cars new technology they're improving
our lives this is just the cost of new
technology people are going to die
instead what we said is we're not going
to go back to horses and Buggies but
we've got to make these safer and we
worked hard to put safety standards in
place that got us crash testing airbags
seat belts and a number of other safety
measures and we've got to take that same
determination and rigor when it comes to
making social media safer for our kids